>> Laura: SINGER R. KELLY IS
SPEAKING OUT FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE BEING ARRESTED AND CHARGED
ON TEN COUNTS OF FELONY
AGGRAVATED SEXUAL ABUSE.
OF YOUNG GIRLS.
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF EVERYTHING
FROM CHILD PORNOGRAPHY TO
RUNNING A CULT IN THE PAST
25 YEARS BUT KELLY MAINTAINS HIS
INNOCENT THAT HE IS THE REAL
VICTIM.
>> I DIDN'T DO THIS STUFF.
THIS IS NOT ME.
I'M FIGHTING FOR MY LEAP LIFE.
Y'ALL ARE KILLING ME WITH THIS.
[SCREAMING]
>> ROBERT.
>> Y'ALL TRYING TO KILL ME!
YOU ARE KILLING ME!
SOME JUST DON'T WANT TO BELIEVE
IT'S TRUE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BELIEVE IT.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOT
EXCLUSIVELY, AN OLD FRIEND,
DR. DREW PINSKY, AN ADDICTION
SPECIALIST AND DOCTOR TO THE
STARS.
DR. DREW, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT INTERVIEW?
HE'S OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY
EMOTIONAL, EXPLOSIVE.
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT GAYLE
KING FOR A MOMENT THERE.
>> YEAH, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU,
LAURA, BY THE WAY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS IS A LOT
OF CELEBRITIES THE DEMAND
SCRUTINIZED LATELY AND THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDF
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDR
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDH
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDM
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMED,
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDF
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDR
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDM
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDB
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMEDD
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN FRAMED.
I'M FEARFUL THIS GUY COULD HURT
HIMSELF.
HE REALLY IS, HIS BACK IS
AGAINST THE WALL.
HE'S FINANCIALLY AND VERY
SERIOUS TROUBLE.
HE COULDN'T AFFORD HIS BAIL.
HE COULDN'T AFFORD CHILD
SUPPORT.
TODAY HE WAS ARRESTED ON THIS.
HE CAN'T HAVE ACCESS TO HIS
CHILDREN.
HE'S BEING ACCUSED OF VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES.
HE IS IN BIG TROUBLE, AND HE IS
IN DESPERATE STRAITS.
I'M ACTUALLY WORRIED ABOUT THIS
GUY.
>> Laura: WELL, DOESN'T SEEM
TO SOME EXTENT, CAN YOU TELL,
IT'S DIFFICULT.
IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE IT'S AN
ONGOING REALITY SHOW DRAMA.
THE STANDING UP, HITTING HIS
CHEST, IT SEEMS -- IT SEEMS
CHOREOGRAPHED A LITTLE BIT.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT.
YOU ARE.
>> WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS
YOUR THINKING TO YOURSELF, I
THINK HE DOFFED PROTEST TOO
MUCH.
IT'S TOO MUCH, IT'S EXCESSIVE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN'T KNOW FOR SURE.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A LOT OF
CELEBRITIES WITH A NEW LENS.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE ALL WOKEN UP
FROM THE SLUMBER OF THE 70s
WHEN ANYTHING GOES.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE LYRICS FROM
MUSIC OF THAT ERA, THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT 14-YEAR-OLD HALF
THE TIME.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, WE HAVE BEGUN
TO SCRUTINIZE THESE PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE IDOLIZED MERELY BECAUSE
OF THEIR MUSIC OR THEIR
APPEARANCE ON TELEVISION OR
MOVIES, AND IT'S BEEN SEDUCTIVE
AND IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THINGS VERY
REALISTICALLY.
>> Laura: HE TALKED ABOUT WHAT
THE PARENTS OF THE GIRLS, THE
ALLEGED VICTIMS, THEIR ROLE IN
ALL OF THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHAT'S YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
HER?
>> RIGHT NOW?
I AM SEEING HER.
SHE'S 21.
I'M SEEING HER.
>> SHE'S 21.
DID YOU START SEEING HER AT 17?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> DID YOU HAVE SEX WITH HER
WHEN SHE WAS 17?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ABSOLUTELY NOT, ALTHOUGH HER
PARENTS WANTED ME TO.
>> Laura: AGAIN, DR. DREW.
I MEAN, COULD THAT HAPPEN?
I GUESS IT GOOD.
>> YOU MUST NOT OF SEEN THE
MICHAEL JACKSON "LEAVING
NEVERLAND" DOCUMENTARY.
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE ALLEGATIONS
ARE TRUE OR NOT, YOU SEE HOW FOR
SOMEBODY TO BE SEDUCED, TO    TO
SEDUCE THE YOUNG PERSON, YOU
HAVE TO SEDUCE AN ENTIRE FAMILY.
WE ELEVATE PEOPLE WITH FAME TO
SUCH A DEGREE, WE ARE EASILY
SEDUCED BY IT AND IT'S POSSIBLE.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT HAS
ACTUALLY GONE ON.
A COUPLE THINGS THAT JUMPED OUT
AT ME ABOUT HIS INTERVIEW THAT
I'VE OUT WERE INTERESTING.
ONE IS HE COMPARTMENTALIZED A
LOT.
HE TALKED ABOUT R. KELLY VERSUS
ROBERT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS HE HAD SOME
VERY SERIOUS TRAUMA HIMSELF,
THAT SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRAUMATIZED THINK.
COMPARTMENTALIZE THEMSELVES AND
THEIR EMOTIONS AND THAT
SOMETIMES IS HOW THEY CARRY OUT
THINGS THAT ARE NOT GOOD.
THESE COMPARTMENTALIZED PART IS
DISAVOWED, THAT'S NOT ME.
I'M REALLY ROBERT.
THEY CAN DO SOME AWFUL STUFF AND
BE A GOOD PERSON AT THE SAME
TIME.
THAT'S ONE THING THAT JUMPED OUT
AT ME IN THIS PARTICULAR
INTERVIEW.
THERE SEEMED TO BE A GOOD DEAL
OF COMPARTMENTALIZATION.
THE OTHER THING THAT I SEE
CELEBRITIES DO ALL THE TIME, THE
NAME THEY USE OUT IN THE WORLD,
R. KELLY VERSUS ROBERT, IT'S NOT
JUST COMPARTMENTALIZATION.
THE THING YOU KNOW OF AS THE
CELEBRITY, THEY DISTANCE
THEMSELVES FROM IT AS THOUGH
IT'S A CARTOON CHARACTER, SO
WHEN PEOPLE CRITICIZE THAT
CELEBRITY R. KELLY, THE     IT D
CELEBRITY R. KELLY, THE     IT E
CELEBRITY R. KELLY, THE     IT N
CELEBRITY R. KELLY, THE     IT T
GET TO ME, ROBERT.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS, YOU MENTIONED THE
ISSUE WITH MICHAEL JACKSON AND
HBO IS OUT WITH A NEW
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT MJ CALLED
"LEAVING NEVERLAND."
IT DETAILS YEARS FOR SUPERSTAR
ALLEGEDLY ABUSED TWO YOUNG BOYS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE'S NO THOUGHTS ON THIS
IS WRONG OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
HE TOLD ME IF THEY EVER FOUND
OUT WHAT WE WERE DOING, HE AND I
WOULD GO TO JAIL.
FOR THE REST OF OUR LIVES.
>> Laura: DR. DREW, WHY IS
THIS COMING OUT NOW?
I MEAN, IT WAS -- HE WAS ON
TRIAL.
HE WON, THERE WERE SETTLEMENTS.
HE'S DEAD.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY ARE TRUE OR NOT BUT THE
DOCUMENTARY SHOWS THE GROOMING
PROCESS, PRECISELY HOW IT
HAPPENS.
IF YOU SAW OPRAH'S INTERVIEW
AFTER THE "LEAVING NEVERLAND" I
CAN PARK, SHE ABOUT IT.
HOW THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
IT IS SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE DRAWN
INTO.
IT'S NOT PAINFUL AND IT'S NOT AN
ATTACK.
IT'S A GROOMING PROCESS.
BY THE SAME TOKEN, BECAUSE THEY
LOVED MICHAEL JACKSON, THEY
WANTED TO PROTECT THEM, THEY HAD
ALL THESE AMBIVALENT FEELINGS
THAT WHEN THEY REALLY WOKE UP TO
WHAT HE HAD BEEN DOING TO THEM,
THERE WAS A FLOOD OF EMOTIONS
AND THEN THERE WAS A DESIRE TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
THE THEORY HERE, IF THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE, THEY
FINALLY GOT ENOUGH DISTANCE.
IN BOTH MEN'S' CASE, IT WAS THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE CHILDREN THAT
THEY STARTED TO LOOK AT THE
CHILD AND GO OH, MY GOD,
SOMETHING DID -- SOMEBODY DID
SOMETHING TO ME WHEN I WAS YOUNG
AND IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE AND THE
EMOTIONAL FLOOD BROKE THROUGH.
SOMEONE CHOSE TO TELL THE STORY,
WHETHER IT'S TRUE OR NOT.
>> Laura: HE'S NOT AROUND TO
DEFEND HIMSELF.
NONE OF US KNOWS IF IT'S TRUE OR
FALSE.
THE DIFFICULTY.
>> I THINK WE ARE WAKING UP FROM
A SLUMBER.
I REALLY DO.
I BELIEVE WE ARE WAKING UP FROM
A SLUMBER FROM THE '70s.
ALL THE YEARS I WAS ON "LOVE
LINE," I WAS SAYING THERE WERE
HORRIBLE THINGS GOING ON AND WE
WERE ACCEPTING IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PICTURES OF
MICHAEL JACKSON RUNNING AROUND
OF THE KIDS, YOU GO OH, MY GOD.
WE WERE ALL GROOMED INTO
EXCEPTING THAT.
W.
MACK OF HISTORY WHERE A LOT OF
THINGS WERE ACCEPTABLE THAT WERE
NOT ACCEPTABLE.
>> Laura: I THINK A LOT OF
THINGS ARE STILL ACCEPTABLE -- I
DISAGREE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE IN FAMILY
OUR TV.
THAT'S ALL OUT THE WINDOW.
>> I AGREE.
WE ARE WAKING UP.
>> Laura: I THINK THE ENVELOPE
IS PUSHED.
>> YOU ARE CORRECT.
I DON'T DISAGREE THROUGH IT ALL
BUT THERE IS STUFF WE ARE WAKING
UP TO AS THOUGH WE HAVE BEEN IN
SOME KIND OF WEIRD SLUMBER.
LOOK AT THE LYRICS OF SONGS FROM
THE '70s AND THINK ABOUT WHAT
THESE ROCK STARS WERE DOING WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE OH, THEY ARE
ROCK STARS.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO?
WE ARE WAKING UP.
WE DO MICHAEL JACKSON RESPONDED
TO SOME OF THESE ALLEGATIONS IN
AN INTERVIEW ON "60 MINUTES" IN
2009 WITH ED BRADLEY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IF I WOULD HURT A CHILD, I
WOULD SLIT MY WRISTS.
I WOULD NEVER HURT A CHILD.
>> DO YOU STILL THINK THAT IT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO SHARE YOUR BED
WITH CHILDREN?
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
WHY NOT?
>> Laura: HE WENT ON TO SAY AS
LONG AS IT'S PLATONIC.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
NOTHING OKAY ABOUT IT.
I DON'T CARE WHO THE 30-YEAR-OLD
MAN IS.
I DON'T CARE WHO HE IS.
I DON'T CARE IF HALF OF HIS
BRAIN TO SHE WAS GONE, NO, NO,
NO.
THAT'S NOT OKAY.
YOU WATCH THE DOCUMENTARY, KIDS
TALK ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD GO TO
TOY STORIES AND LOAD UP WITH
BASKETS FULL OF TOYS.
HE WOULD NOT LET THAT HAPPEN AS
A PARENT.
YOUR JOB IS TO TEACH KIDS HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY GET IN THE WORLD, IN
THE WORLD TO BE A VERY
FRUSTRATING PLACE.
YOU DON'T GET WHAT YOU WANT ALL
THE TIME.
THAT VERY -- JUST GOING TO THE
TOY STARS.
>> Laura: WHERE WERE THE
PARENTS?